There are two different APIs for this: device orientation
and device motion, both of which are really interesting. Device
orientation tells you which way the device is tilted and
which way it's pointed. This can be useful for implementing
a virtual joystick for example, or implementing a compass. Device
motion gives you events and information about what forces are
being applied to the device. Which makes it easy to
tell if you're shaking the device but it also let's
you include and exclude gravity. This means it can tell you how the device is
oriented too. It's really a strict superset
of device orientation but it's a bit more
challenging to use in that way. So
given these descriptions in which of these scenarios
do you think you would use device orientation
And in which would you use device motion?